This lecture is about the latent
Dirichlet allocation or LDA.
In this lecture, we're going to
continue talking about topic
models.
In particular,
we are going to talk about some extensions of
PLSA, and one of them is LDA or latent
Dirichlet allocation.
So the plan for this lecture is to
cover two things.
One is to extend the PLSA with prior
knowledge that would allow us to have
in some sense a user controlled PLSA, so
it doesn't blindly just listen to data
but also would listen to our needs.
The second is to extend the PLSA as a
generative model fully generated model.
This has led to the development of
Latent Dirichlet Allocation or LDA.
So first let's talk about the PLSA
with prior knowledge.
In practice, when we apply PLSA to
analyze text data, we might have
additional knowledge that we want to
inject to guide the analysis.
The standard PLSA is going to blindly
listen to the data by using maximum
likelihood estimator.
We are going to just fit data as much as we can
and get some insight about data.
This is also very useful, but sometimes
a user might have some expectations
about which topics to analyze.
For example, we might expect to see
retrieval models as a topic in
information retrieval.
We also may be interested in certain
aspects such as battery and memory when
looking at the opinions about the
laptop, because the user is
particularly interested in these
aspects.
Now, a user may also have knowledge
about the topic coverage.
And we may know which topic is
definitely not covered in which
document or is covered in the document.
For example, we might have seen those
tags topic tags assigned to
documents.
And those tag could be treated as
topics if we do that, then a document
that can only be generated using topics
corresponding to the tags already
assigned to the document.
If the document is not assigned to a tag,
we're going to say there's no way for
using that topic to generate the
document.
The document must be generated by using
the topics corresponding to the
assigned tags.
So the question is, how can we
incorporate such knowledge into
PLSA?
It turns out that there's a.
A very elegant way of doing that, and
that's all incorporated such knowledge
as priors on the models.
And you may recall in Bayesian
inference we use prior together with
data to estimate parameters, and this
is precisely what will happen.
So in this case we can use maximum a
posteriori estimate, also called map
estimate, and the formula is given
here.
Basically is to maximize the posterior
distribution probability and this is a
combination of the likelihood of data
and the prior.
So what would happen is that we're
going to have an estimate that listens to
the data and also listens to our prior
preferences.
We can use this prior, which is denoted
as P of Lambda to encode.
All kinds of preferences and
constraints.
So for example, we can use this to
encode the need of having precisely 1
background the topic.
Now this can be encoded as a prior
because we can say the prior for the
parameters is only a non zero if the
plan does contain one topic that's
equivalent to the background language
model.
In other words, in other cases if it's
not like that, we're going to say
supplier says it's impossible.
So the probability of that kind of
model setting would be 0 according to
our prior.
So now we can also, for example use the
prior to force particular choice of
topic to have a probability of a
certain number.
For example, we can force the document
D to choose topic one with
probability of 1/2.
Or we can prevent a topic from being
used in generated document.
So we can say the third topic should
not be user generated.
Document D will set to the Pi value to
0 for that topic.
We can also use the prior to favor set
of parameters with topics that assign
high probabilities to some particular
words.
In this case, we're not going to say
it's impossible, but we're going to
just strongly favor certain kind of
distributions.
And you will see example later.
The map can be computed using a similar
EM algorithm as we have used for that
maximum likelihood estimator with just
some modification to smallest
parameters reflect the prior
preferences.
And in such a estimate, if we use a
special form of the prior called
conjugate prior, then the functional
form of the prior will be similar to
the data.
As a result, we can combine the two and
the consequences that you can basically
convert the influence of the prior into
the influence of having additional
pseudo data because the two functional
forms are the same and they can be
combined.
So the effect is as if we had more
data.
And this is convenient for computation.
It doesn't mean conjugate prior is the
best way to define the prior.
So now let's look at the specific
example.
Suppose the user is particularly
interested in battery life of a laptop,
and we're analyzing reviews.
So the prior says that the distribution
should contain one distribution that
would assign high probabilities to
battery, and life.
So we could do say there's a
distribution that's entirely
concentrated on battery life and we all
priors is that one of your distributions
should be very similar to this.
Now if we use map estimator with the
conjugated prior, which is Dirichlet
prior Dirichlet distribution based on
this preference, then the only
difference in the EM algorithm is in
the M step.
When we re estimate word distributions,
we are going to add.
Additional counts to reflect our prior
right?
So here you can see the pseudocounts
are defined the based on the
probability of words in our prior.
So battery obviously will have a high
pseudocounts similar life would have
also high pseudocounts or the other
words.
We have 0 pseudocounts because their
probability is zero in the prior and
when you see this is also controlled by
a parameter mu and
We're going to add mu multiplied by the
probability of W given our prior
distribution to the connected counts.
When we re estimate the when we re
estimate the this world distribution
right?
So this is the only step that changed
and the changes happened here and
before we just collect the counts of
words that we believe have been
generated from this topic.
But now we force this distribution.
To give more probabilities to these
words by adding them to the
pseudocounts so to artificially in
effect, we artificially inflated their
probabilities and to make this
distribution we also need to add this
many pseudocounts to the denominator.
This is the total sum of all the
pseudocounts we have added for all the
words.
This would make this again a
distribution.
Now, this is a intuitively very
reasonable way of modifying the EM
algorithm and theoretically speaking,
this deal works, and it computes the
map estimator.
It's useful to think about two specific
extreme cases of Mu.
Now can you picture.
Think about what would happen if we set
Mu to Zero.
Well, that's essentially to remove this
prior, so mu in some sense indicates
our strength on prior.
Now what would happen if we set Mu to
positive Infinity?
Well, that's to say this price is so
strong that we're not going to listen
to the data at all.
So in the end you can see in this case
we can do make one distribution fixed
to the prior.
You see why?
When mu is Infinity, we basically let
this one dominate.
In fact, we are going to set this one.
to precise this distribution, so in
this case it is this distribution, and
that's why we said the background
language model is in fact a way to
enforce a prior, because we force
one distribution to be exactly the same
as what we give, that's the background
distribution.
So in this case we can even force the
distribution to entirely focused on
battery life.
But of course this won't work well
'cause it cannot attract other words,
it would affect the accuracy of
counting.
Topics about the battery life so in
practice mu is set somewhere in
between, of course.
So this is one way to impose our prior.
We can also impose some other
constraints.
For example, we can set any parameters
for constraints, including zero as needed.
For example, we may want to set one of
the pis to 0.
And this would mean we don't allow that
topic to participate in generating that
document.
And this is only reasonable, of course,
when we have prior knowledge
that strongly suggests this.